function G can be thought of as a
translated or shifted version of f of X
is equal to x squared write the equation
for G of X now pause this video and see
if you can work this out on your own
alright so whenever I think about
shifting a function and in this case
we're shifting a parabola I like to look
for a distinctive point and on a
parabola the vertex is going to be our
most distinctive point and if I focus on
the vertex of F it looks like if I shift
that to the right by 3 and then if I
were to shift that down by 4 at least
our vertices would overlap I would be
able to shift the vertex to where the
vertex of G is and it does look and will
validate this at least visually in a
little bit so I'm going to go minus 4 in
the vertical direction that not only
would it make the vertices overlap but
would make the entire curve overlap so
we're going to make we're going to first
shift to the right by 3 and we're going
to think about how would we change our
equation so it's shift F to the right by
3 and then we're going to shift down by
4 shift down by 4 now some of you might
already be familiar with this and I go
into the intuition a lot more depth in
other videos but in general when you
shift to the right by some value in this
case we're shifting to the right by 3
you would replace X with X minus 3 so
one way to think about this would be y
is equal to f of X minus 3 or Y is equal
to instead of it being x squared you
would replace X with X minus 3 so it'd
be X minus 3 squared now when I first
learned this this was counterintuitive
I'm shifting to the right by 3 the
x-coordinate of my vertex is increasing
by 3 but I'm replacing X with X minus 3
why does this make sense
well let's graph the shifted version
just to get a little bit more intuition
here once again I go into much more
depth in other videos here this is more
of a worked example so this is what the
shifted curve is
look like think about the behavior that
we want right over here in X equals
three we want the same value that we use
to have when x equals zero when x equals
zero for the original f zero squared
with zero y equals zero we still want y
equals zero well the way that we can do
that is if we are squaring zero in the
way that we're going to square zero is
if we could if is if we subtract three
from X and you can validate that at
other points think about what happens
now when x equals 4 4 minus 3 is 1
squared it does indeed equal 1 the same
behavior that you used to get well at X
is equal to 1 so it does look like we
have indeed shifted to the right by 3
when we replace X with X minus 3 if you
replaced X with X plus 3 it would have
had the opposite effect you would have
shifted to the left by 3 I encourage you
to think about why that actually makes
sense so now that we've shifted to the
right by 3 the next step is to shift
down by 4 and this one is a little bit
more intuitive so let's start with our
shifted to the right so that's y is
equal to X minus 3 squared but now
whatever Y value we were getting we want
to get 4 less than that so when x equals
3 instead of getting y equals 0 we want
to get y equals 4 or less or negative 4
when x equals 4 instead of getting 1 we
want to get Y is equal to negative 3 so
whatever Y value we were getting we want
to now get or less than that so the
shifting in the vertical direction is a
little bit more intuitive if we shift
down we subtract that amount if we shift
up we add that amount so this right over
here is the equation for G of X G of X
is going to be equal to X minus 3
squared minus 4 and once again just to
review replacing the X with X minus 3 on
f of X that's what shifted shifted right
by 3 by 3 and then subtracting the 4
that shifted us down by 4 shifted down
by 4 to give us this the next graph and
you can
visualize or you can verify visually
that if you shift each of these points
exactly down by four we are we are
indeed going to overlap on top of G of X